qui est en VI voà chers
collègues bonjour
euh je suis très très heureuse que nous
nous retrouvions sur un sujet
d'importance qui concerne le statut de
l'élu et je suis très heureuse
d'accueillir en vrai comme l'on
dit un certain nombre d'élus qui nous
font l'honneur d'être là aujourd'hui et
tout aussi heureuse de saluer euh ceux
et cell qui nous font le plaisir de
participer à cette audition et qui sont
en visio donc vraiment merci à tous je
vais essayer d'être la plus bref
possible pour faire l'introduction
puisque nous disposons d'une heure pour
cette table ronde et je voudrais que les
collègues rapporteurs qui sont tous de
chaque
côté de de de nos de nos invités puis
surtout poser des questions donc je
voudrais juste rappeler pour nos invités
le travail que nous avons engagé depuis
maintenant la fin octobre date à
laquelle nous nous sommes reconstitués
pucequ'il y a eu des élections
sénatoriale nous avons donc entrepris ce
qu'on appelle une mission flash sur le
statut de l'élu pourquoi c'est parce que
le Sénat depuis de nombreuses années a
émis des propositions à fait adopter
certaines d'entre elles et considère au
vu des démissions au vu déjà de la
situation de 2020 nous avions un certain
nom de communes qui n'ont pas eu de
candidats d'autres un peu plus de 300
qui ont des conseils municipaux
incomplets du nombre de démissions qu'il
y avait là un désenchantement
démocratique qui pouvait provoquer une
sorte de catastrophe démocratique parce
que si les les nos citoyens deviennent
extrêmement fragiles où ont peut d'
pétence pour l'engagement civique et
l'intérêt général je pense que il y a un
enjeu d'une gravité démocratique de
cohésion sociale considérable donc nous
avons décideré au Sénat d'entreprendre
cette mission flash sur trois
volets alors nous avons appelé ça le
statut de l'élu parce qu'on a pas
d'autres mot mais peut-on faire un
statut de l'élu je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas des dispositions qui facilitent
l'engagement et l'exercice du mandat un
premier volet qui traite de des
indemnités de leur nécessaire
revalorisation euh ce ce premier volet a
fait l'objet d'une présentation et d'une
validation par la délégation le 16
novembre et nous avons deux volets euh
ou deux tomes si je puis dire qui font
l'objet entre autres de cette audition
aujourd'hui et qui sont conduits par les
rapporteurs qui sont là Gérard laelec
Pascal Martin Nadine bellerau guilè
Pantel il y a aussi notre ami Thierry
KIC Agnès can alors quand on commence
une liste on en oublie donc ça y est ça
c'est fait pardonnez-moi euh et donc ces
deux volets qui sont extrêmement
importants portent sur la facilitation
l'exercice du mandat et le troisième
volet qui est tout aussi important parce
qu'on y pense rarement mais c'est sans
doute un des éléments de frilosité de
l'engagement c'est l'aprèsmandat
c'est-à-dire qu'arrive-t-il quand le
dimancheoir les élections municipales ne
nous sont pas favorables nous avons
décidé de de de mettre fin à à nos
mandats donc voilà l'objet de notre
réflexion sachant que le président du
Sénat a annoncé au Congrès des Maires
que le Sénat présenterait en début
d'année 2024 c'est-à-dire quasiment
demain matin une proposition de loi sur
le statut de l'élu car il y a urgence à
agir les prochaines élections ayant lieu
en 2026 il nous semble que des
dispositions doivent être adoptées avant
pour que l'engagement des futures
équipes municipales se fassent dans des
conditions davantage sécurisé alors très
rapidement nous avons donc le plaisir de
de de cet échange grâce à
l'initiative de nos corapporteurs que je
que je remercie vraiment puisque je sais
que certains d'entre vous sont très
connus par certains d'entre nous voilà
mais aussi à
l'initiative d'association des lu nous
sommes toujours heureux de partager de
belles rencontres donc je voudrais
saluer Daniel Fidelin qui est juste en
face de moi qui a été maèire de
montivillet qui est normand et qui a été
député merci merci beaucoup à vous
d'être là je voudrais saluer Yve Guenard
qui est en visio qui est maire de re
merci à vous Monsieur le Maire d'être là
je veux saluer Christine dain qui est en
visio également et qui est maire
d'épouville je veux saluer marcosol le
maire de Langogne et qui est en visio
merci vraiment à vous trois et puis
Laurent
Rousell qui est aussi voilà en face de
moi qui est adjoint au maire de
Fontainebleau et Solal ga qui est
conseiller municipal à montauan et qui
est secrétaire général de l'Association
des jeunes élus de France et dans dans
le dans notre rapport nous souhaitons
vraiment qu'il y ait un engagement de
citoyen assez représentatif de la
constitution de notre société et nous
sommes absolu de la composition de notre
société nous sommes ravis euh que des
jeunes veuillent s'engager que nous
puissions traiter la particularité de
leur de leur contraint donc je vous cède
la parole et je propose de donner la
parole dans l'ordre que j'ai évoqué si
vous voyez pas d'inconvénient donc on
vous demande à chacun je crois que c'est
un consigne qui vous a été donné de vous
contraindre à un exercice très
sénatorial euh qui qui qui enfin qui
nous permet de vous martyriser si je
suis dire mais très positivement un peu
contraint et après je laiss parole au
cèguespporteurs qui ont s doute beaucoup
de questions et à tous mes collègues que
je salue donc monsieur Fidelin si vous
voulez entamer cette audition je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente je
sais que je n'ai que 5 minutes
semble-t-il c'est un peu court mais je
me rappelle quand même que lorsque
j'étais parlementaire si on dépassa le
temps Madame la Présidente taper sur le
micro et on devait
cesser vousz complémentaire par le nos
échanges oui bien sûr bien sûr il y a
pas de souci oui quelques mot madame la
Présidente cher collègue ancien collègue
plutôt j'ai été 37 ans élu sans verser
bien sûr dans la nostalgie ou
l'explication un petit peu de mes de mes
activités passées mais j'ai était 37 ans
élu donc 24 ans conseiller général 31
ans maire et 10 ans député avec bien sûr
des échecs des victoire c'est ainsi la
vie politique m'a donné quand même une
bonne vision des inquiétudes et des
préoccupations donc pendant toute cette
période puisque j'avais des j'avais
comme mandat des mandats municipaux mais
aussi des mandats nationaux en tant que
député alors euh une bonne vision donc
je disais des des des mais aussi des
satisfactions bien sûr tout dépend bien
quand on est élu de
l'activité professionnelle donc de l'âge
et du type de mandat pour ma part
j'étais assureur j'avais une profession
libérale donc ça donne comme toutes les
professions libéral qui s'engage dans la
vie politique donne un certain nombre
d'avantages notamment la liberté du
temps de de de de regarder un peu son
agenda euh mais aussi des inconvénients
parce que lorsque moi en ce qui me
concerne lorsque que j'ai été élu député
après plusieurs tentatives mais lorsque
j'étais élu député j'avais 54 ans 54 ans
un mandat de député c'est 5 ans 59 et à
59 ans si j'étais élu de nouveau pas de
souci puisque ça me mettait à 64 ans
quasiment à l'âge de la retraite mais si
j'étais
battu j'avais quand même quelques
difficultés parce que j'étais loin de la
retraite et la retraite des professions
libérales c'est 65 ans donc et lorsque
vous êtes assureur ou toute autre
activité libérale que vous avez vendu
votre affaire parce que moi j'étais
obligé de vendre mon affaire mon cabinet
d'assurance puisque je n'avais pas la
possibilité d'exercer donc les deux
activités professionnelles et politiques
donc ça me posait un problème j'ai eu la
chance bien sûr d'être élu donc pour le
deuxè mandat ce qui m'a menait à à l'âge
de la retraite mais ça c'est un souci
c'est une préoccupation qu'il faut tenir
compte dans l'avenir je crois que
lorsqu'on est qu'on s'engage dans un une
fonction politique une fonction d'élu et
bien on de on doit penser me semble-t-il
et anticiper parce que ce sont bien sûr
des CDD c'est je dis toujours que ce
sont des CDD et les CDD il y a
obligatoirement donc une fin alors
euh en ce qui concerne les
indemnités on avait à cette époque la
possibilité du cumul des mandats qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui donc en ce qui
concerne le j'étais maire de la commune
de manvilette une petite commune rurale
de 800 habitants j'étais vice-président
de la Communauté d'Agglomération ce qui
fait que le cumule de mandat me donnait
des indemnités donc substantiellesfin
qui me permettait de palier donc au
soucis financiers mais quand même
lorsque vous êtes maire d'une commune
montivier commune de 16000 habitants
c'était 2500 € maximum de plafond fond
et moi je ne prenais pas la totalité
puisque généralement ça grève le budget
et beaucoup de collègues maires ne
prennent pas la totalité donc 1700 € si
j'enlève les charges sociales et la
fiscalité bien sûr les impôts on se
retrouve avec 12200 c'est-à-dire un gros
SMIC pour être maire d'une commune de
16000 habitants donc ça c'est aussi une
préoccupation et un souci donc dans ce
qui en ce qui concerne les indemnités et
puis euh en tant qu'élu national euh en
tant que parlementaire à cette époque on
avait la possibilité encore de cumul de
mandat avec euh le maire je qualifierais
ses indemnités de députés plus les
indemnités de maire donc
d'une revenu relativement correct qui me
posait absolument pas de souci mais euh
on arrive à à la sortie de mandat la
sortie de mandat pose quand même
quelques problèmes
euh ça dépend à quel âge on arrive euh
lorsqu'on est profession libérale je
l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure quand on arrive à 59 ou à 59 ans
on a des difficultés à retrouver un
emploi quand vous avez cédé votre
affaire c'est absolument impossible de
retrouver un emploi donc on se retrouve
peut-être commercial dans une entreprise
mais quand on a été patron de son
affaire c'est quand même quelque part un
peu un peu difficile alors euh j'ai eu
la chance puisque j'ai fait un deuxième
mandat d'être battu enfin pas la chantti
de battu mais j'ai été
battu donc à 1 an de la retraite j'avais
donc l'indemnité de maire et et de
vice-président de l'agglomération donc
qui me posait pas de problème
particulier mais il fallait faire une
transition jusqu'à la retraite et cette
transition donc c'est cette indemnité me
permettait de la faire et je me
suis présenté dans une ville de 16000
habitants à montivier donc au coi après
au bout des 2 ans j'ai gagné euh mais
j'ai gagné je n'ai fait qu'un mandat je
n'ai fait qu'un mandat et la sortie du
mandat pose quand même quelques
difficultés parce que euh vous retrouvez
sans rien du tout vous retrouvez sans
rien du tout et puis l'indemnité des
retraites pose aussi quelques
difficultés en ce sens que en ce qui me
concerne bien sûr j'avais avec le cumul
de mandatircant que j'avais la la
sécurité sociale m'a posé beaucoup de
soucis puisque
avais j'avais fait 5 ans d'activité en
tant que salarié tout à fait au début de
ma carrière enfin au début de ma
carrière professionnelle pas d'élu ma
carrière professionnelle et j'avais donc
une indemnité de retraite de 50 €
mensuel et à partir de 2000 1er janvier
2013 les élus doivent cotiser
euh donc doivent cotiser la sécurité
sociale et moi j'avais liquidé ma
retraite 6 mois avant puisque je ne
pensais pas du tout reprendre activité
salariée mais on m'a dit alors j'ai
sollicité donc la la SCU en disant mais
écoutez j'aurais aimé avoir ma retraite
de en tant que élu puisqu'on n obligéit
6 mois après à cotiser mais on m'a dit
non vous avez liquidé vos 60 € par mois
donc vous n'avez pas le droit j'ai donc
18000 € de cotisation pendant toute
cette période que je dois dire j'ai mis
quelque part un peu à la
poubelle jeis j'ai été frustré bien sûr
je suis intervenu notamment par
intermédiaire de mes collègues et
collègues élus mais pour l'instant je
n'ai absolument aucune réponse et ça
c'est un souci je sais pas s'il y a
beaucoup de d'autres
euh collègues anciens collègues dans ce
niveau-là à ce niveau-là mais je pense
que c'est quelque chose quand même qui
est qui est important alors moi j'aurais
une pensée aussi pour les
collaborateurs nos collaborateurs qui
sont des gens particulièrement
collaborateurs et collaboratrices bien
sûr sont des gens particulièrement ent
dévoués qui ne compte pas leurs heures
et ils ont besoin de reconnaissance et
je pense que lorsque vous êtes battu et
que vous retrouvez derrière le rideau
lorsque vous faites votre discours et
que ils sont en pleur et que le
lendemain matin vous devez faire donc le
l'Inter enfin vous devez
faire une réunion pour dire bah c'est
terminé maintenant et bien je pense que
c'est quand même un peu délicat et les
l'Assemblée nationale et peut-être le
Sénat
doivent donc agir en reconnaissance bien
sûr auprès des collaborateurs et des
collaboratrices et ça ça me paraît
quelque chose d'essentiel bien sûr nous
mettons tout en œuvre nous en ce qui
nous concerne en tant qu'élu
pour pour les soutenir je pense que ça
c'est quelque part quelque chose
d'important alors
euh vous sentez bien qu' je déjà loin ah
ben je vais arrêter
alorsespère
reviendra sur votre témoignage parce que
il y a des il y a des enfin des
informations que vous donnez qui sont
extrêmement pertinente et qui font bien
partie de notre champ de de
préoccupation monsieur
Fidelin je suis désolé j'ai ce rôle
affreux mais je suis sûre que vous me
pardonnez mais on reviendra sûrement
voilà merci Merci à VOUS puis-je passer
la parole à Monsieur le Maire de
re qui est très connu
ici alors Monsieur yvgenard si vous nous
entendez vous nous faites
signe allô
allô bon je propose peut-être que du
coup on fasse une inversion madame
domain mer ah voilà Monsieur
Guenard non est-ce qu'en attendant
Joseph je peux voilà madame domain
peut-être madame le ou la mère
d'pouville voilà si vous nous entendez
je vous entends très bien Madame on vous
entend pas micro s'il vous plaît madame
la mère mais il est bronché mon micro on
ne vous entend pas il est branché il est
branché mon
micro euh mon micro est
branché Monsieur le Maire de
[Rires]
Langogne
alors
ah très bien al
est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter donc vous parlez au maire de
langingogne pardon excusez-moi bonjour
oui allez-y je vous prie JPH juste pour
information j'entendais très bien ma
collègue de mon côté donc je suis marcol
bonjour à tous madame la Présidente mer
de bonjour à tous les membres de la
commission donc
euh un un bonjour un peu plus soutenu à
à à notre sénatrice Guilain Pentel ma ma
chère ma chère Guilen merci merci pour
cette proposition et cette nouvelle
expérience comme j'ai pu j'ai pu te le
dire donc je m'appelle marcosol je suis
maire d'une commune d'un peu moins de
3000 habitants euh en LAZER Le plus beau
département de France vous l'imaginez
bien euh il se trouve que euh c'est une
commune qui est au sein d'un territoire
d'une communauté de communes du
hautalier Margeride euh de composé de 10
communes sur un bassin de vie euh qui
qui dépasse allègrement le cadre
départemental puisque nous sommes à la
confluence de l'Ardèche euh de la Haute
Loire et de la looserre sur un bassin de
vie qui représente 13500 habitants à peu
près 55 communes et nous sommes le
bourcentre donc avec euh évidemment des
des charges de centralité importante et
pas forcément les moyens qui vont avec
euh donc la la la toute la difficulté
euh pour nous les élus euh j'ai oublié
de peut-être de préciser aussi que je
suis actif je continue à travailler euh
et il se trouve que je suis
fonctionnaire public territorial euh je
travaille au sein de la du Centre de
gestion de la fonction publique
territoriale de la lozer et je suis un
agent itinérant c'est-à-dire d que
j'interviens
euh dans les collectivités que peuvent
être les mairies les communautés de
communes des Petr des syndicats et
cetera pour per des des des des des des
situations où on peut être par exemple
en mode dégradé parce qu'on a un agent
qui est en maladie on a un agent qui est
qui a muté et cetera et ou besoin d'un
renfor particulier et j'interviens sur
tous les volets eu administratif de de
ce que peut être demandé par une
collectivité territoriale donc inutile
de vous dire que c'est quelque chose que
je connais maintenant depuis une
trentaine d'années assez bien vous avez
dit Madame la président qu'il y avait
trois trois grands sujets effectivement
euh à aborder dans dans dans vos travaux
et j'ai eu le temps bien évidemment de
d'interroger un petit peu mes collègues
et j'imagine que les collègues ici
présents en font la même analyse moi je
rejoins bien évidemment euh le monsieur
Fidelin sur sur tout ce qu'il a pu nous
présenter au niveau des indemnités la
première chose c'est que moi ce que
j'aimerais pouvoir dire si c'est que euh
s'il doit y avoir mesure il faut qu'elle
bénéficie à tous les élus et quelle que
soit la taille de la collectivité il ne
faut pas seulement penser à mon sens au
maire euh il y a aussi des adjoints des
conseillers délégués des simples
conseillers qui prennent du temps euh
pour pour faire pour accomplir la
mission que le que camère peut leur
demander il faut revaloriser j'en suis
j'en suis persuadé les indemnités pour
refléter mieux leur engagement et leur
charge de travail euh je pense qu'il
faut peut-être aussi selon l'estrat
s'interroger sur la l'obligation de les
percevoir parce qu'il y a je vois trop
dans les zones hyper rurales euh des
élus qui renoncent à en tout à toutes
parti de leurs indemnités parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément les moyens euh de
faire autrement et donc ça passe à mon
sens par une revalorisation de la
dotation particulière de l'élu locale
euh c'est une évidence euh moi je
voulais attirer l'attention aussi dans
l'exercice du mandat d'un maire sur la
la difficulté grandissante en matière de
recrutement et ça ça peut être aussi un
point qui peut être euh très compliqué
pour un élu et qui peut lui faire dire
que euh et lui faire le faire réfléchir
sur un engagement ou un éventuel
renouvellement d' d' d'unun d'un
engagement moi je rencontre trop de
collectivités dans les situations euh
dégradées et je pense que conforter le
rôle de l'élu au sein de sa collectivité
c'est aussi un travail à faire vers les
métiers de la fonction publique
territoriale pour que lui puisse
s'assurer d'avoir une réponse euh quand
il a quand il a besoin d'agent euh sur
sur sur son territoire il y a des
difficultés grandissantes par exemple
pour trouver des assurances typiquement
la responsabilité civile on a de plus en
plus de mal à trouver des contrats
d'assurance responsabilité civile vous
imaginez un petit peu la difficulté que
ça que ça peut
euh ça ça peut générer euh et je pense
qu'il faut aussi garantir une protection
adéquate
euh à l'exercice des fonctions notamment
pour tout ce qui est assurance maladie
il faut il faut il faut pas euh occulter
ça en ce qui concerne les les les
indemnités euh
et et les salaires euh moi je pense que
il faut vraiment que je le dis tout à
l'heure une compensation sur une
enveloppe dédiée il faut maintenir les
cotisations retraite d'un d'un élu euh
tel qu'il pouvait l'avoir quand il était
dans ses fonctions privées euh je vous
donne un exemple moi je je je continue à
travailler à 60 % c'està direire je
travaille 3 jours par semaine j'ai la
chance d'avoir une des services très
structurés avec des élus euh présents
qui peuvent très bien palier mon absence
sans aucune difficulté alors bien
évidemment les semaines sont longues
mais elles le sont pour tout le monde et
je vais pas m'en plaindre donc moi j'ai
je touche les indemnités d'élus à
hauteur à peu près de 1500 1600 € par
mois mon salaire est à peu près
équivalant à peu près 1500 €. du coup je
me fais ma propre retraite euh et donc
je suis obligé en quelque part de
surcotiser par rapport à à à aux
cotisations que j'ai aujourd'hui euh bon
c'est un choix évidemment mais ça ça
c'est un point un point point d'
achauffement un point un peu compliqué
euh au-delà de l'aspect indemnitaire je
pense que dans l'exercice du mandat
parce que c'est aussi c'est aussi la
réflexion que mène que mène cette
commission
euh moi je je je crois qu'il faut qu'on
qu'on revienne un petit peu à un
renforcement de la démocratie locale euh
je le constate au quotidien il faut à
mon sens simplifier les règles
d'exercice des mandats locaux augmenter
un petit peu les marges de manœuvre euh
des élus que nous sommes euh moi j'ai
j'ai par par par moment l'impression
d'avoir un manque de confiance de la
part de l'État si mais je je tiens quand
même à pondérer cela en disant que le
couple maire préfet en tout cas ce qui
en ce qui me concerne moi élu de la
looser fonctionne parfaitement bien euh
et j'ai la chance aujourd'hui il me
semble nous avons la chance sur notre
territoire d'avoir un préfet très à
l'écoute très proactif voilà je crois
que les les élus ont aussi besoin pour
être rassurés dans leur mandat de le
qu'on le redonne un peu d'ingénierie ce
dont il manque cruellement alors moi je
le dis pour les les plus anciens entre
guillemets oui au retour de l'athesat je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de ce qui
était un ATESAT cet interlocuteur moi
que j'appelais l' l'interlocuteur
privilégié qui venait de la DDE venait
entre guillemets régler les soucis et
discuter et se faire le relais entre la
collectivité et l'État et principalement
matière d'urbanisme aussi d'ingénierie
c'était quand même euh important je
crois qu'il faut aussi dans les travaux
que vous menez prendre en compte les
spécificités des territoire on n'a pas
tous les mêmes les mêmes problématiques
euh je reviendrai pas mais l'exemple je
reviendrai pas trop dessus mais
l'exemple roi en ce moment ben c'est la
zéro artificialisation net où on demande
en quelque part à un élu de faire plus
avec moins euh moi j'ai quand même je
suis inquiet dans les dans les zones je
parle de ce que je connais en zone hyper
rurale où j'entends des maires de
collègues qui me disent que ils n'iront
pas au devant de leurs concitoyens pour
leur expliquer qu'il va falloir réduire
de 60 ou 70 ou 80 % les surface
constructible euh il y en a même qui ont
qui ont pu dire en conférence de Mare
que nous organise qu'on organise
régulièrement notre Pr président euh de
communauté de communes qui ne
traverseraiit plus la place du village
après ça donc il y a il y a il y a une
vraie difficulté
là-dessus pour ce qui est des nouveaux
élus moi je pense que si j'ai encore un
peu de temps qu'il faut il faut les euh
les obliger à suivre une formation à mon
sens il faut pas simplement leur
proposer une formation à mon sens il
faut il faut les obliger euh peut-être
en ciblant quand même les objectifs pour
certains hein euh on aura peut-être un
élu en face de nous qui a plus
d'ppétence pour l'urbanisme et les
finances ou l'étativ V par exemple et
qu' il y aura pas forcément besoin
d'aller le d'aller le le former
là-dessus il faut maintenir la la
rémunération des agents dans la mesure
du possible qui viennent en agents
salariés qui viennent prendre des
fonctions électives pour se faire il
faut il faut rentrer dans des mesures de
compensation pour les entreprises les
sociétés les collectivités qui les
emploient par de la fiscalité de
l'allement de charg fiscal je je pense
je pense qu'il y a d'autres choses de
possible euh moi je voudrais aussi
parler de Al excusez-moi je vais vite
parce que je n'ai que je n'ai que peu de
temps euh mais euh les la durée cumulée
des des absences autorisées du crédit
d'Ur c'est 800 heur par an j'arrondis si
un maire il n'a pas suffisamment de
services correctement structuré 800 he
ça n'est pas suffisant donc il lui faut
obligatoirement s'entourer d'élu plus
disponibles comme des retraités et quand
un élu n'est pas indemnisé par sa
collectivité et qu'il n'est pas rémunéré
pendant son pendant euh l'absence chez
son employeur on demande à la
collectivité de l'indemniser à hauteur
de 16,91 par heure 16,91 € par heure si
mes chiffres sont bons et c'est limité à
72 he par
an à mon sens ça ne correspond pas à la
réalité euh de du travail de des des
élus en France et à mon sens ça n'est
pas à ça n'est pas à la collectivité
àorter ça il y a d'autres pistes je
pense qu'il faut peut-être aussi que
j'imagine vous avez vous avez vous avez
pu voir euh il faut pouvoir travailler
sur la flexibilité des horaires des élus
dans leur emploi euh peut-être envisager
des des dispositifs de télétravail de
droit euh quand cela est possible
évidemment très bien je vous propose
Monsieur le Maire euh merci beaucoup
pour cette intervention encore une fois
je vous demande de de m'absoudre dans
l'exigence de temps pour que chacun
puisse intervenir et je suis sûr que les
collègues seront ravis de de de
continuer voilà cet échange par le biais
de question donc je crois que maintenant
tout va bien donc nous devrions pouvoir
retrouver monsieur Yve Guenard qui est
maire de re Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur le Maire y dit ceux qui
vous
connaissent tout va
bien non bon madame domain peut-être oui
voilà madame
domain madame le Maire oui bonjour
madame la Présidente parf merci merci
beaucoup donc je vous
propose de d'articuler votre
intervention autour des deux thématiques
donc les deux seconds volets de notre
mission faciliter l'exercice du mandat
sachant que la question des indemnités a
déjà été largement évoqué dans le
premier volet et la seconde partie de
votre intervention si vous voulez bien
sur l'après mandat merci beaucoup madame
le Maire ou la maire je sais pas comment
vous souhaitez qu'on vous appelle
j'aime bien le maire parce que il faut
presque avoir un caractère d'homme pour
être maire d'une bourgade comme la
mienne écoutez je je je pense que vous
voyez les réactions dans la salle très
spontané et très dynamique à votre
appréciation donc Madame le Maire je
vous en prie merci madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes et tous donc je me
présente très rapidement je suis
Christine domin maire d'épouville 2800
habitants quasiment on passe de devenir
je pense qu'on abordera les 3000 avec
les nouvelles constructions d'ici
quelques
temps je suis élu depuis mai 2020
conseillère municipale depuis 1989 élu
adjoint en 1995 et donc élu maire en mai
2020 je suis salarié du
privé je suis chef du service juridique
et assurance d'un opérateur portuaire
sur le port du Havre
et quand quand mon ancien maire a décidé
de de s'arrêter et que tous les adjoints
s'arrêtaient aussi sauf moi la ma
première préoccupation ça a été mon
travail je me suis comment si je me
présente comment je vais concilier les
choses avec un poste à
responsabilité il a fallu que je demande
à mon employeur si il y voyait pas
d'inconvénient parce que si j'avais eu
un nom définitif je ne je me serais pas
présenté c'était pas possible parce que
je pouvais pas faire le choix de de
briser ma carrière entre guillemets je
suis à 9 ans de la retraite j'ai 56 ans
j'ai fait des études donc j'ai été un
petit peu décalé dans dans le démarrage
et la difficulté en fait c'est bien sûr
comme je suis aussi pas maire je suis
aussi conseillère communautaire je suis
13e membre du bureau communautaire le
havrein métropole et bien en fait ça
nécessiterait que je sois tout le temps
tout le temps disponible et pour la
mairie et pour la la communauté urbaine
je n'ai pas de délégation à la
communauté urbaine et j'avoue que
j'étais presque heureuse qu'on ne m'en
propose pas parce que je ne sais pas
comment j'aurais pu concilier ça avec
mon travail euh donc la mairie la
communauté urbaine c'est extrêmement
compliqué quand on travaille quand on
est salarié du privé je suis extrêmement
comprimé je le dis très franchement et
et et comment faciliter les choses il
faudrait pouvoir permettre euh alors moi
je ne suis pas dans le le fonctionnariat
je ne peux pas me mettre en
disponibilité je ne vais pas reparler
des indemnités euh les collègues on vont
se sont exprimés ou vont s'exprimer à
nouveau mais effectivement à 9 ans de la
retraite je je ne peux pas m'arrêter de
travailler j'ai une indemnité de 1578 €
par mois euh donc qui couvre nous tout
hein c'estàdire tous mes déplacements et
cetera c'est sur mon indemnité euh donc
c'est pas possible à 9 ans de la
retraite de m'arrêter donc euh voilà un
petit peu le contexte dans lequel je
suis je suis extrêmement comprimée c'est
pour ça que je suis vraiment ravie de
pouvoir pouvoir témoigner parce que si
ça peut un petit peu aussi révéler ce
qui se passe quand on travaille dans le
privé euh je suis pas la seule parce que
parmi mes adjoints j'ai six adjoints et
deux conseillers délégués euh sur les h
euh alors on est neuf avec moi on en a
trois euh qui qui ne sont pas en
activité professionnelle tout le reste
est en activité professionnelle avec des
des des diversités euh et c'est moi qui
qui suis la plus on va dire la plus
enququinée parce que parce que je
travaille dans le privé je suis je suis
la seule à à travailler dans le privé
donc voilà voilà la situation ce n'est
pas bien simple alors faciliter le
mandat j'ai beaucoup beaucoup cherché
comment on pouvait faire parce que
j'avoue que je sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire je me suis permis en faisant une
petite contribution auprès de du
sénateur Pascal Martin par écrit de dire
mais est-ce qu'il ne faut pas trouver
une solution pour les entreprises venant
pour les entreprises du privé justement
euh c'est plus difficile bien sûr pour
pour pour un salarié de de prendre un
mandat de maire un mandat d'adjoint ou
un mandat encore plus élevé où là ça
devient quasiment impossible je pense
au-delà audelà de MRE de de continuer à
travailler je ne sais pas quelle est la
solution mais en tout cas l'avantage
aussi d'avoir des des des je pense des
élus du du privé qui travaillent c'est
qu'on a aussi une vision des choses un
petit peu un petit peu plus plus précise
peut-être par rapport à la vie active
euh moi je vois que ça ça m'aide
beaucoup en fait d'avoir mon poste de
responsable de service juridique
assurance parce que parce que Ben une
mairie je le compare souvent je compare
souvent ma mairie un peu à une une
entreprise avec 2800 habitants il faut
être bon en compat faut être bon en
juridique euh puisque on a plusieurs
problématiques euh et je suis dans une
strate de commune où je je n'ai pas la
structuration totale qui me permette à
la limite juste de piloter je suis aussi
obligé de faire certains travaux d'agent
territorial parce que si je n'a pas à la
manœuvre si je puis dire et bien il y a
des manquements en fait on n'est pas
structuré on essaie un petit peu de
s'améliorer ce qu'on est en train de
changer de strat finalement à éppouville
mais là moi si je ne mets pas la main à
la patte en faisant le travail de de
d'un agent territorial et bien ça ça ne
peut pas fonctionner en fait donc en
fait on est vraiment au four et au
moulin quand on est dans une strade de
commune comme la mienne et qu'en plus on
est en activité professionnelle donc
donc je je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire ou j'ai pas de d'idée précise sauf
à
dire si on veut continuer à attirer des
vocations parce que on a quand même
plusieurs soucis le fait de travailler
en éteint ça c'est sûr d'être en
activité professionnelle c'est compliqué
surtout quand on a une commune qui
commence à être un petit peu importante
euh mais pas que on a aussi bien sûr
tout le contexte que l'on connaît par
rapport aux élus et il est vrai que je
peux tout à fait comprendre qu'à un
moment donné les les les vocations se
décourage hein parce que parce que c'est
pas du tout simple d'avoir et des
problématiques liées au fait qu'on
travaille mais aussi des problématiques
liées à la façon dont on est parfois
traité moi j'avoue que j'ai eu de par
mon expérience les deux hein donc la
problématique d'être une élu en activité
professionnelle plus quelques gros Dossi
très compliqués qui ont fait que j'ai
été très très mal mené ainsi que que mes
adjoints bien sûr c'est toujours le
maire qui est qui est visé en en premier
dans ce genre d'affaires et je vous
avoue que ça m'a traversé l'esprit de me
dire bon après tout je m'arrête j'ai une
carrière en parallèle et puis euh et
puis bah tant pis pour j'arrête la
mairie quoi en fait hein donc et
j'arrête par voie de fait le le conseil
communautaire mais à un moment donné je
me suis dit non c'est quand même pas
normal qu'on soit comprimé comme ça et
que qu'on puisse pas exercer son mandat
donc c'est dans cet esprit que je me
suis permis d'en parler en l'occurrence
à à niè caniller et à à Pascal Martin
que je salue au passage
euh il faut arriver à trouver une
articulation et encore une fois je n'en
ai pas la solution mais trouver une
articulation qui permette à à et je vais
parler que de mon expérience he des gens
du privé de pouvoir exercer des mandats
en ayant quand même une forme de
sécurité euh liée à l'après-mandat bien
sûr mais aussi une sécurité financière
sans justement retrouver 100 % de son
salaire en l'occurrence moi je suis
cadre euh je je je gère un service j'ai
un bon salaire en tant que cadre par
rapport à mes fonctions et ça ne
m'aurait pas du tout dérangé d'avoir une
diminu d'ailleurs j'ai une diminution
puisque j'ai j'ai deux demi-journées
j'ai j'ai un 80 % en fait hein ce qui
n'est absolument pas suffisant mais
c'est pour ça que je mors sur mon temps
personnel de manière extrême sur mes
weekends et même sur mes nuits pour
arriver à tout à tout gérer mais il
faudrait arriver pour attirer aussi un
petit peu et faciliter la tâche des des
élus comme moi arriver à trouver une
articulation qui permette à l'entreprise
privée de de de de faciliter aussi le la
libération de de ces salariés pour
exercer un mandat alors je ne sais pas
sous quelle forme je ne sais pas sous
quelle articulation mais je pense que
c'est aussi valorisant pour pour les
collectivités d'avoir aussi des élus qui
qui ne soient pas que des retraités je
n'ai rien contre les retraités j'espère
atteindre l'âge de la retraite
sereinement mais qui ne soit pas non
plus que dans le fonctionnariat parce
que c'est plus simple dans le
fonctionnariat que dans le privé et et
qu'on puisse avoir justement cette
palette un petit peu éclectique de
représentants
élus et qui de par leur expérience quel
qu'ell soit ben sont sont utiles à mon
sens à à la collectivité à son fonction
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de
votre témoignage je crois que vous posez
les bonnes questions et nous comptons
sur nos collègues pour nous apporter des
des réponses ou des suggestions merci
beaucoup madame le Maire à tout à
l'heure par le BIA des questions je
propose Monsieur Laurent Roussel si vous
êtes volontaire
pour voilà vous exercer ce c'était ce ce
ce moment un peu difficile où on vous
contraint beaucoup par le temps parce
que voilà on en a certainement un temps
d'échange très r merci Monsieur rel je
rappelle que vous êtes adjoint au maire
de Fontainebleau très belleeville aussi
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les membres de la commission
merci de de me recevoir je ça tombe très
bien que je passe après madame le Maire
de Normandie qui est en Normandie je ne
sais plus le le nom de la commune
éouville puisque c'est un peu la même
situation sauf que je suis allé un petit
peu plus loin dans dans le le les
statuts de de l'élu puisque je suis
moi-même également alors je suis élu
depuis 2008 en d'abord conseil municipal
puis depuis 2014 en tant qu'adjoint et
puis j'ai aussi maintenant depuis 2 ans
les fonctions de Premier Vice-Président
de la comité d'Agglomération du Pays de
fontainebau donc je suis bien engagé
localement et je j'ai la particularité
comme Madame le Maire de d'exercer dans
une entreprise privée donc une grande
entreprise donc une grande plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de de salariés
depuis plus de 30 ans maintenant
d'ancienneté dans cette structure donc
j'ai été je suis confronté encore
toujours puisque je continue à exercer
mon activité professionnelle un peu au
même au même problème de concilier
l'activité professionnelle et l'activité
d'élu euh puisque donc dès que j'ai été
alors au départ j'étais adjoint au
patrimoine donc le le maire de l'époque
m'avait donné une délégation qui était
considérée comme étant peut-être plus
compatible mais en plus j'ai depuis j'ai
récupéré les finances et j'ai récupéré
évidemment la la la première
vice-présidence àacité d'agglomération
donc je suis bien engagé donc je me suis
adressé à mon employeur et je je lui ai
notifié qu'effectivement j'étais j'étais
élu et demanda des des des des heures de
mandat comme c'est prévu dans le statut
de l'élu sauf que quand on est élu on a
les heures de mandat qui sont pas
rémunéré par l'employur évidemment mais
on a aussi des réunions qui sont
improvisées avec souvent la veille on
apprend qu'il y a des réunions donc on
prend des RTT au dernier moment parce
que les HE de mandat c'est 3 jours avant
donc c'est pas très d'une grande
souplesse et puis euh et puis le soir on
doit partir parce qu'on a aussi des
réunions quasiment tous les soirs donc
on est obligé de partir à l'heure donc
quand les autres restent pour terminer
des dossiers bah Vous vous êtes obligés
de partir donc vous êtes mal vu donc
très rapidement les les relations avec
mon employeur se sont dégradé
et du coup j'ai été muté sans mon
consentement j'étais responsable
d'activités importantes et j'ai été muté
dans évidemment dans dans une activité
qui correspondait plus du tout à ce que
je faisais avant progressivement j'ai
perdu toutes mes responsabilités j'ai
perdu travaillant dans cé un secteur
bancaire j'ai perdu les pouvoirs donc
j'ai quasiment plus de pouvoir
bancairirees donc du coup et on me l'a
reproché alors il se trouve qu'on l'a
reproché même par écrit donc évidemment
j'ai utilisé ce qui existait
c'est-à-dire discrimination et j'ai donc
saisi les prudents pour demander la
résiliation de mon contrat de travail il
me reste encore maintenant 5 6 ans avant
le avant la retraite donc c'est encore
pas tout à fait là et et demander donc
la rupture de mon contrat de travail et
et demander donc que que le la
discrimination soit soit déclarée contre
mon employeur ça veut dire que j'ai donc
saisi les prudents il y a 2 ans et demi
maintenant que les procédures sont très
longues que le l'employeur évidemment a
demandé des renvois pour le jugement
pour faire rallonger les choses j'ai
subi des pressions importantes du
harcèlement et cetera donc tout ce qui
va avec évidemment le jugement a
finalement eu lieu l'audience de
jugement pardon a eu lieu il y a
quelques semaines mais le le délibéré
n'aura lieu que l'année prochaine voir
l'année suivante s'il y a pas de partage
des des prudhommes et puis après comme
me dit mon avocat il y aura au moins 3
ans pour le l'appel qui que ce soit moi
ou l'employeur qui gagne et puis après
il y aura peut-être la cassation donc
grosso modo il se passera rien comme dit
l'avocat avant 5 6 ans il y aura pas de
jugement donc peut-être que d'ici là je
serai je serai déjà à la retraite avant
même avant même que le jugement soit
soit définitif voilà donc c'est c'est
c'est contraignant c'est fatiguant euh
c'est et ça ça se ça s'ajoute et et ça
provient aussi du fait qu'on est
finalement la discrimination dans le
contrat dans le code du travail c'est
pas très protecteur parce que c'est
difficile à le prouver quandême des
preuves alors moi j'ai j'ai quand même
la chance d'avoir des écrits mais même
avec ça on me dit oui mais peut-être que
ça suffira pas parce qu'au fond et
cetera et cetera et puis il y a des
choses qui sont un peu anciennes donc il
y a peut-être prescription enfin bref
donc le l'employeur l'avocat de
l'employeur je voulais dessus donc c'est
c'est très très compliqué à mettre en
œuvre donc alors qu'une une vraie
protection moi je pense qu'effec ement
une vraie protection comme c'était le
cas ça a été brièvement le cas mais mais
pas opérationnel puisque c'était dans le
col général des collectivités
territoriales mais pas dans le code du
travail donc c'était c'était pas
opérationnel mais une vraie protection
on est quand même quand on est élu on
est quand même responsable et sérieux
donc on peut arriver quand même à faire
à répartir je crois que quand on est on
est maire maire d'une ville on a
l'habitude de gérer beaucoup de choses
en même temps donc on est capable de
faire la part des choses bon moi je je
suis entre guillemets 4 joint enfin
aussi à la comité d'agglomération donc
on sait quand même qu'on a qu'on a du
temps aussi pour travailler on n'est pas
pris à 100 % ou sinon de toute manière
on peut pas s'arrêter de travailler
comme comme disait madame le Maire on a
on a besoin d'un salaire donc on a voilà
on va pas demander enfin moi je pense
que de toute manière les indemnités on a
beau demander des augmentations ça
compensera pas le salaire qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir par par ailleurs donc
ça c'est le le le premier sujet c'est la
protection et comme j'ai été harcelé que
c'était compliqué le mon médecin m'a'
m'a vraiment demandé de m'arrêter donc
je me suis arrêté pendant plusieurs mois
sur à toutes les pressions que je
subissais et en veillant à respecter la
loi c'est-à-dire pour poursuivre mes
fonctions il fallait que le médecin
écrive dans l'arrêt de travail que
j'étais que j'étais élu ce qui a été
fait sauf que j'ai repris le travail
avant l'audience de jugement et 2 mois
après la veille la veille du jugement
l'employeur a sorti un courrier de le la
CPAM lui demandant de rembourser les
indemnités journalières parce que
j'avais continuer mes fonctions même si
j'avais respecté tout ça et du coup
puisque j'avais été compensé par la
convention collective m'avait versé mes
salaires et me demande de rembourser les
salaires sur une durée de 7 mois charges
incluses donc même pas ce que j'ai reçu
mais les charges en plus donc ça vous
imaginez le la veille du jugement donc
mais je mon avocat bon c'est c'est
encore une fois de plus une
discrimination vers un élu puisque
puisque c'est même pas fondé comme comme
demande mais le l'avocat pas pu le en
parler puisque c'était pas officiel
c'était des discussions entre avocats
donc il a attendu le le lendemain du
jugement pour m'envoyer un mail en me
disant ben merci de nous dire de quelle
manière vous allez vous allez nous
rembourser et si vous remboursez pas on
fera des retenues sur salaire comme
comme on est comme on est en droit de le
faire voà donc moi je lu ai demandé de
faire un recours contre cette parce que
moi j'étais pas destinataire du courrier
la CPM donc c'était à l'employeur de
faire un recours évidemment il a refusé
donc c'est moi qui ai fait un recours
contre la CPM un recours contre
commission amiable de la sécurité
sociale donc j'ai entamé une deuxième
procédure donc j'ai la procédure des
prudom et maintenant j'ai la procédure
contre la CPAM alors j'essaye j'ai j'ai
essayé de de contacter la CPM et cetera
donc la CPM est en train de regarder
puisque je suis quand même dans mon bon
droit même donc il faut sortir toutes
les les arrêts de travail tout ce qui
est confidentiel il faut lever la
confidentialité puisque c'est marqué
enfin c'est très agréable à suivre tout
s'ajoute on paye des frais
d'avocat c'est c'est c'est un peu
compliqué voilà donc c'était le c'était
pour non seulement il faudrait protéger
un peu mieux mais en fait il y a un
certain nombre de de procédures et
cetera qui sont méconnu parce que là
c'est une méconnaissance de la part de
la sécurité sociale voilà c'est quelques
mots merci beaucoup Monsieur l'Adjoint
vous avez d'ailleurs témoigné au Congrès
des Maires euh parce que cette situation
vous vous l'avez dit avec beaucoup de
pudeur extrêmement difficile illustre
euh enfin on va dire une situation
sitation qui peut se produire et qui
pose au-delà de de de l'engagement qui
pose beaucoup de difficultés et on a
déjà eu par ailleurs il y a quelques
années connaissance du point que vous
évoquez la difficulté de
concilier la prolongation de de
l'engagement pendant l'arrêt maladie et
l'exigence de de remboursement des
indemnités merci vraiment de votre
témoignage donc il nous reste deux
témoignages avec plaisir avant un petit
temps de question donc
je pense que Monsieur Guenard le maire
de re que connaît bien Nadine
burau aujourd'hui nous sommes connectés
monsieur Monsieur le Maire voilà je je
vous propose comme aux autres une
contrainte je suis désolé 5 petites
minutes pour que nous ayons le temps de
de question donc sur la facilitation de
de l'engagement du du enfin du citoyen
pour exercer son mandat et le de deè
volet c'est la sortie du mandat en
quelque sorte merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Maire et désolé de ces incidents
techniques ah euh
alors donc ben je propose vraiment
Monsieur le Maire je suis confuse nous
allons y arriver est-ce bon sinon je
propose à cela le G alors ça va vous
faire très drôle Monsieur Je de parler
de la fin du mandat vu votre âge mais
est devant nous tous donc il faut aussi
évoquer tous ces sujets bon ça marche
toujours pas pour notre ami Monsieur
Guenard bon on s'en occupe donc
voilà donc Solal ga qui est connu de
certains d'entre nous notamment de
Monsieur Bonhomme vous êtes conseiller
municipal à Montauban et vous êtes
secrétaire général d'une association
aussi extrêmement importante comme
toutes les association d'élus
l'association des jeunes élus de France
vous avez vous aussi un petit crédit de
5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les élus euh tout d'abord
permettez-moi de vous remercier de me
donner la possibilité de m'exprimer
aujourd'hui j'espère que ce témoignage
court de 5 minutes permettra à certains
élus de de s'identifier alors oui je
m'appelle solalj je suis ÉU dans une
commune de 64000 habitants à Montauban
depuis 2020 c'est mon premier mandat
j'ai la chance d'appartenir à la
majorité hein qui a été reconduite au
côté du maire de Montauban pour un 4e
mandat j'ai également le bonheur d'être
pleinement engagé au sein de
l'Association des jeunes élus- de France
qui est une association transpartisane
qui regroupe plusieurs centaines de
jeunes élus âgés de 18 à 35
ans nous avons à ce propos
lancé une commission portant sur la
conciliation entre l'engagement et la
vie professionnelle et personnelle à
l'issue d'une rencontre avec madame la
ministre en charge des collectivités
territoriales et je pense nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir sur quelques
propositions en vue de cette réforme du
statut de l'élu local j'ai eu également
la chance d'être élu très jeune d'avoir
des responsabilités très jeune et la
réalité c'est que rien ne prépare au
mandat local ni aucune école ni aucune
université je vais revenir un petit peu
sur ce que disait Monsieur le Maire lors
de sa première intervention s'agissant
de la formation des élus c'est vrai que
je suis assez intimement attaché à la
liberté donc je sais pas s'il faut
vraiment contraindre les élus à se
former mais il y a une véritable
nécessité une désinformation une absence
de formation et c'est vrai que la
réalité je dirais politique parfois est
assez contraignante pour ceux qui exerce
un premier
mandat d'abord une formation qui
permettrait d'en apprendre davantage sur
le fonctionnement des collectivité
territoriale c'est vrai que je parle
notamment du du budget je suis juriste
de formation spécialité finances publi
c'est vrai que c'est c'est un sujet qui
très peu sexy ou très peu d'élus locaux
s'y intéressent aussi pour prévenir de
de certains comportements qui peuvent
engager des conflits d'intérêts qui
contrairement à l'imaginaire collectif
ne naissent pas d'une véritable volonté
de violer une règle de droit mais
davantage d'une négligence en fait je
crois que c'est inutile de préciser
qu'il est plus facile d'exercer un
mandat lorsqueon appartient à la
majorité plutôt qu'à l'opposition et si
l'entrée du mandat se révèle-être un
événement que l'on projette avec enrein
la sortie du mandat je dois l'avouer et
vous le disiez madame la Présidente
c'est pas quelque chose auquel je pense
tout
particulièrement cependant c'est à
anticiper et c'est vraiment à préparer
et je pense que les difficultés d'une
reprise de l'activité professionnelle
après cette parenthèse qui est le mandat
local et bien est profondément
conditionné à la situation et à
l'activité professionnelle en question
vous disiez tout à l'heure monsieur
l'adintomire effectivement c'est vrai
qu'une personne qui est fonctionnaire
aura davantage de facilité à retrouver
un emploi une personne personne qui est
salariée elle devra peut-être retoquer
chez son ancienne entreprise retrouver
un nouveau patron une personne exerçant
une profession libérale aura perdu une
partie de sa clientèle devra aller
rechercher une clientèle je pense qu'il
y a vraiment une réflexion à faire
autour de de ça et je pense que ça peut
également s'accompagner l'aprèmandat à
travers des formations ainsi qu'une
validation des acquis je crois que c'est
déjà le cas mais peut-être pousser cette
notion de validation des
acquis également euh une proposition qui
a été le fruit de cette commission au
sein de l'Association des Jeunes d'élu
de France c'est l'autorisation la mise
en place de la
visionférence comptabilisée dans le
quorum au sein des assemblées
délibérantes locales pour les conseils
locaux je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas comptabilisé dans le quorum et c'est
vrai que c'est une possibilité ça peut
être un axe de réflexion notamment pour
celles et ceux qui exercent une activité
professionnelle et qui du fait de la
distance et bien font un pouvoir alors
qu'il pourrai justement participer
pleinement à je dirais à cet exercice à
ce temps de la vie démocratique locale
enfin dernier point si vous me le
permettez un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur et qui aussi
fait le le fruit d'une grande réflexion
au sein de l'association des jeunes élus
de France du fruit également d'une
rencontre avec Madame la Ministre de la
Jeunesse et du service national
universel celle de la création d'un
véritable statut de l'élu étudiant comme
il peut exister pour les élus étudiants
dans les syndicats là en l'espèce il est
question de jeune élu moi j'ai j'ai été
élu et étudiant j'étais en 2e année de
de de licence de droit je me rappelle
lorsque j'ai fait la campagne des
municipales en 2020 il est vrai que j'ai
sacrifié une partie de de cette année je
regrette rien c'était une expérience
formidable mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le droit ne permet pas aux jeunes
étudiants de s'engager pleinement dans
le mandat de l'élu on on dit à tort je
crois que la jeunesse se désengage la
réalité c'est tout l'inverse la jeunesse
elle s'engage de plus en plus mais s
loin du manda local aujourd'hui les
jeunes s'engagent davantage auprès
d'associations auprès d'ONG pour des
causes notamment l'environnement la
protection des femme la cause animale
mais euh se désengage du mandat puisque
il y a très peu de possibilités de
conciliation entre les études et
l'engagement voilà et quelques quelques
chiffres hein qui qui parlent de même
nous sommes je crois environ 520000 élus
locaux et en matière de de de jeunesse
entre guillemets même si je pense qu'il
ne faut pas opposer les générations
d'abord parce que la jeunesse ne dure
qu'un temps mais ça voudrait dire qu'il
y a deux types d'élus des jeunes élus et
des élus moins jeunes je pense que ça a
pas de sens mais aujourd'hui sur 520000
élus en France et bien nous avons
seulement 6 % des élus qui sont âgés de
moins de 35 ans je pense que ça ça
nécessite vraiment un axe de réflexion
voilà je pense que parmi tous ces
éléments j'ai atteint mon mon temps de
parole madame la la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs merci pour
votre attention euh merci beaucoup pour
votre témoignage monsieur parce que
l'engagement des jeunes fait vraiment
partie de non seulement de nos
préoccupations mais de notre volonté de
permettre cette cet engagement alors
nous avons appris que Monsieur Guenard
maire de rely ami de Madame bellerau
puisque c'est son département un
problème technique donc il va se
connecter par téléphone en attendant si
vous êtes ok je propose pour gérer le
temps de laisser peut-être des questions
à nos corapporteurs sachant chers amis
que nous avons monsieur Cédric chevalier
qui a aussi
émis c'est bien ça ça son son souhait de
poser une question non ah ouf alors
peut-être d'abord nos rapporteurs en
vous proposant d'être aussi excellent
que d'habitude dans la concision nous en
fait on on était surtout là pour vous
écouter et le sujet comme tu disais
François sur les jeunes euh moi
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez une
suggestion c'està-dire comment vous
aider dans les études en même temps pour
pouvoir vous engager parce que le sujet
en effet c'est que voilà il y a de la
relève et est-ce que vous voyez quelque
chose de pratiqueau pratique qui
pourrait permettre de vous d'aider des
jeunes à s'investir estce que c'est des
voilà je là voilà dans votre vie au
quotidien vous vous avez ça mais comment
on peut le faire
partager merci madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice merci pour votre
question c'est vrai qu'il on a quelques
propos i à faire alors après je pense
que c'est vraiment à discuter mais je
prends l'exemple des élus étudiants ceux
qui sont investis dans des organisations
syndicales qui sont élus au sein des
universités eux bénéficient des
dispenses d'assiduité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque l'on assiste à un
conseil d'administration un conseil
central au sein d'une université et bien
on peut s'absenter de de cours
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas s'absenter de
cours alors du moins c'est à
l'appréciation assez assez large et
générale du du professeur ou de
l'enseignant on ne peut pas s'absenter
pour un conseil municipal moi-même
j'enseigne à l'université c'est vrai que
j'ai une je dirais une sorte de
flexibilité dans la tolérance de
d'absence mais c'est pas le cas de
chaque enseignant ou de chaque
professeur je pense qu'il y a vraiment
une réflexion à mener sur du moins sur
ce qui est de la disponibilité euh de
l'élu étudiant et puis après moi je suis
ouvert vraiment à toute suggestion mais
disons que je pense que c'est une des
principales une des des des principales
revendications qu'on qu'on pourrait
avoir en tant que élu étudiant du moins
dans dans mes souvenirs c'est ça
oui oui oui oui un vous vous remerciez
de oui vous remerciez de de vos
témoignages pour certains ils sont
édifiants
euh on a nous dans notre travail
préparatoire élaborer huit
recommandations qu'on va naturellement
pas développer ce matin mais avec vos
témoignages tout ça va être
enrichi comp compter sur nous non moi
j'avais juste une question un peu
technique mais qui est apparu au au long
de nos auditions non pas de ce matin
mais préalable à nos travaux concernant
les les règles liées au conflit
d'intérêt au déport qui sont des règles
qui euh peuvent toucher toutes les
communes et qui quelle que soit la
taille des communes et et on a le
sentiment que assez souvent ces ces
règles-là sont méconnues et peuvent
entraîner des conséquences voire pénales
pour des élus locaux et je rejoins solel
ga des gens de totale bonne foi
c'est plus de la négligence et je
voulais savoir si vous avez le sentiment
qu'il faudrait améliorer l'information
et la communication de ces règles qui
touchent encore une fois l'ensemble des
élus conflit d'intérêts et déports merci
je ne sais pas qui veut répondre
monsieur rutsell monsieur Fidelin madame
le
Maire Monsieur rutsell je vous en prie
oui je je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est vrai qu'il y a une méconnaissance
et et quelque part aussi au-delà de la
méconnaissance c'est aussi un manque de
respect quelque part aussi de des
élus c'est enfin certains certains
employeurs sont dans leur sont dans leur
domaine mais n'ont pas très envie de de
savoir ce qui se passe en dehors en
fait
[Musique]
peut-être on peut on peut se connecter
donc on essaie de joindre Monsieur le
Maire ensuite je passerai la parole à gu
et tu
Perets par que je pense que Monsieur le
Maire doit être aussi un
peu stressé de de pas pouvoir joindre on
est vraiment désolé donc Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur le Maire de re si vous
nous entendez je suis
là merci on est très heureux merci de
votre patience merci mille fois donc
mais vous avez aussi un crédit de 5
petites minutes Monsieur le Maire je
suis désolé pour
ces acdent donc je je salue évidemment
vous-même madame la Présidente ainsi que
messieurs et mesdames les rapporteurs et
mes collègues maires je suis moi-même je
vais me présenter maire d'une commune de
2000 habitants dans l'Indre dans le
centre valdeelire depuis octobre 2020 je
suis un ancien cadre supérieur d'un
groupe bancaire coopératif français
j'étais chargé de l'informatique
décisionnelle de la gestion des budgets
du suivi des coûts informatique à la
fois des niveaux nationaux
communautaires et locaux pour le compte
de deux établissements régionaux basé en
Île-de-France et je suis retraité depuis
la fin de
2005 installé à rely d'abord premier
adjint sur le mandat 2014-2020 en charge
notamment des
finances nous avons avec le maire cher
Nadine constaté une dette habysale pour
une commune de notre taille nous avons
fait face en quelques semaines à un
défut faut trésorerie dès le premier
mois de notre prise de fonction nous
avons bien entendu renoncé à l'emprunt
sur toute la durée du mandat et financé
sur subventions et fonds propres tous
nos investissements nous avons euh
supprimé en quelque sorte la fonction
directeur général des service et placer
le maire au cœur du management de la
collectivité entouré de responsables de
pôle assister bien sûr des adjoints au
nombre de 5 depuis la prise de fonction
de maire en 2020
j'ai maintenu cette organisation cette
action de désendettement à hauteur d'un
million d'euros en 7 ans et je poursuis
le programme sur lequel la liste avait
été élu le recours à l'emprunt bien que
mesuré est envisagé pour deux projets
indispensables dans le cadre de
l'intérêt général pour la commune une
maison de santé opérationnelle à horizon
2026 une réhabilitation l'infrastructure
d'assaignissement collectif dans le
cadre d'un schéma directeur don plan
d'action prévu sur 5 ans début dès
l'année prochaine je suis également
président du syndicat intercommunal
d'alimentation en eau potable depuis
2014 et j'ai engagé la même démarche
d'étude patrimonial débouchant sur un
schéma directeur dont le plan d'action
débute dès 2014 aussi moi je voudrais
parler de la difficulté à mobiliser
c'est ce que nous avons pu constater en
2014 en 2020 c'est ce qu'il y aura à
constater encore en 2026 si on y remidie
pas donc le nombre de conseiller pour
une liste à présenter de 19 pour une
commune de notre taille de de notre
strate ce qui signifie évidemment pour
deux pour deux listes en concurrence 38
personnes et s'il y avait un challenger
ce qui n'est pas impossible 57 sur une
commune de 2000 habitants c'est
extrêmement compliqué dans la mesure où
par ailleurs il faut assurer une parité
ce qui est
aussi difficile donc la proposition que
je ferai euh me semble-t-il partagé par
beaucoup serait de de réduire de 4 voire
de 6 le nombre de conseillers euh pour
notre strat mais peut-être pour
l'ensemble des strates à voir sur le
rôle et sur l'engagement euh les
conseillers tous les conseillers veulent
avoir un rôle ils s'engagent sur la
durée ils ont des appétences ils veulent
avoir un rôle et euh pour avoir un rôle
et être efficace et bien on ne peut pas
nindemniser que le maire et les adjoints
il faut indemniser aussi les conseillers
qui s'engagent donc la proposition
serait en effet euh de de d'inclure un
accroissement des crédits du poste
indemnité de manière à pouvoir
indemniser les conseiller qui
souhaiteraient s'engager sur des
spécialités qui évidemment seraient
intéressant pour la pour le pour le
conseil et pour la commune sur la
disponibilité la moyenâge des élus ça a
été dit tout à l'heure je le je le
confirme la moyenne d'âge des élus
locaux en milieu rural est élevée en
majorité des retraités peu de jeunes en
raison de leur activité professionnelle
et donc de la difficulté qu'ils auraient
à se à se disponibiliser donc il nous
faudrait attirer de de jeunes actifs
plutôt un peu diplômés en charge aussi
d'encadrement de manière à avoir euh une
pratique managériale certaine et leur
donner les moyens d'assurer leur mission
d'élu au moyen de crédit d'Ur qui
pourrait être compensé par l'État ou la
collectivité par des dispositifs à
mettre en œuvre une dotation spécifique
de l'État euh je pense même que il
serait peut-être utile euh notamment en
pré-campagne de diffuser des spots
télévisés qui décrivent euh les euh
compensations à un engagement municipal
et qui décrivent les fonctions des
maires et des adjoints et des et des
élus
locaux sur le maire sur le maire euh en
terme de notoriété la fonction reste
notoire mais il y a quand même une
tendance à la banalisation je n'ai pas
de difficulté de ce type dans ma commune
je ne suis pas par ailleurs inquiet pour
ma sécurité je pense qu'il est cependant
indispensable de valoriser la fonction à
la fois de représentant de la population
communale et également garant des
valeurs de la République il y a
peut-être des dispositions à prendre
dans ce sens sur la capacité et la
disponibilité le maire aujourd'hui ça a
été dit je le confirme c'est un chef
d'entreprise un chef d'entreprise de
service public il est entouré de
responsable par grand domaines il manage
la collectivité et c'est de cette façon
que nous fonctionnons à rei il ne peut
plus être celui qui s'appuie totalement
et uniquement sur une secrétaire de
mairie il doit maîtriser la gestion
budgétaire il doit connaître la gestion
des marchés publics il doit comprendre
les infrastructures d'alimentation en
eau potable en assaainissement collectif
et en assaainissement autonome il doit
connaître l'état civil les processus
électoraux les règles de gestion des
cimetière il doit avoir une connaissance
en urbanisme il ne peut pas ignorer les
noix sur l'eau la gestion des rivières
menur d'hom naturel ou non il doit
maîtriser les règles managériales et
mettre en place les outils du management
et connaître unant soit peu les statuts
du personnel et de la fonction publique
territoriale pourquoi doit-il avoir
toutes ses connaissances c'est parce que
au quotidien et dans tous ces domaines
il est appelé à prendre des décisions
immédiates et il doit le faire
évidemment toute connaissance de cause
après au-delà de tout cela il a
représenté la commune aès les services
de l'État du département des chambres
consulaires et de tous les organismes en
relation avec la commune il a à faire
vivre le secteur associatif développer
l'accès à la culture et rencontrer ses
administrés ses commerçants et artisans
ses industriels c'est c'est un travail
euh quotidien c'est un travail à temps
complet le maire avant d'être élu à
cette fonction a généralement une
expérience de conseiller municipal et ou
d'adjoint au maire une expérience
d'adjoint voir de premier adjoint me
semble un prérequis à la fonction de
maire même s'il n'y a pas euh euh
comment dirais-je d'interdit de de de
quelque nature que ce soit pour être
maèire d'une collectivité DISP
pardonnez-moi monsieur vraiment
pardonnez-moi puis-je me permettre de
vous interrompre euh en vous remerciant
vraiment de de de de ce de ce témoignage
et de ce de cette offre d'emploi
extrêmement complète que vous présentez
en décrivant le PO je je je m'autorise à
vous interrompre par parce que je
regarde le le temps et je pense que nous
avons pas mal de questions donc merci
beaucoup Monsieur le Maire nous aurons
sûrement l'occasion par l'intermédiaire
de questions d'approfondir donc je passe
la parole à guilè Pantel ensuite il y a
trois demandes de parole Cédric
chevalier Pascal grunier et Pierrejean
Rochette il nous reste 10 minutes et
Muriel jourin merci chers collègues Guil
merci madame la Présidente ben écoutez
déjà je tiens remercier chacun d'entre
vous chacune et chacun d'entre vous pour
cette témoignages qui sont extrêmement
forts qui sont qui se qui sont
différents mais en même temps qui se
ressemblent que ce soit en communauté
urbaine que ce soit un milieu
extrêmement rural comme l'a décrit le le
maire de
l'angogne les problématiques sont les
mêmes partout mais mais il y a aussi par
rapport
au la conciliation de la vie de la vie
publique de la vie professionnelle mais
il a aussi la vie privée on en a très
peu parlé mais il faut aussi articuler
avec la vie privée de chacun parce que
c'est un socle c'est c'est quelque chose
de de très fort pour pour chacun d'entre
nous donc c'est c'est très difficile et
euh Monsieur G votre votre engagement
est important et et et pour l'avenir euh
c'est vrai que c'est pas très
encourageant quand on entend des
témoignages aussiidifiants que que
Monsieur l'Adjoint mais que ce soit des
entreprises privées mais des grandes
entreprises publiques aussi c'est pas
simple du tout donc il faut il faut pas
se décourager il faut il faut vraiment
continuer dans dans cet engagement et
euh et surtout arriver à concilier aussi
la vie privée c'est c'est quelque chose
de voilà d' d'important je vous remercie
c'était juste un merci merci beaucoup
gellen pour ce témoignage donc je
propose de de prendre deux questions
ensuite une autre série de donc notre
collègue Cédric chevalier et Pascal
Greny puis puis Pierre Jean Rochette et
Muriel jour
Cédric oui merci madame la Présidente
tout d'abord vraiment remercier
l'ensemble des des témoignages
extrêmement intéressant moi je voudrais
euh en fait poser un peu une question un
peu transversale c'estàd que on sent
quand même sur l'ensemble des élus que
quel que soit d'ailleurs leur âge ou
leur expérience que il y a pas forcément
un un travail en amont d'arriver d'être
élu en fait sur les droits les devoirs
en fait d'appréhender complètement ce
que doit être demain avec l'ensemble du
périmètre de ce que doit être un élu pas
forcément dans les fonctions en tant que
tel mais tout ce qui découle autour de
la vie de l'élu on sent qu'il y a pas
forcément une euh une une comment une
approche ou en tout cas une un certain
nombre de d'éléments qui leur permettent
de de bien l' apprpréhender ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que à aucun moment j'ai senti que quand
on était salarié c'était une chance pour
l'entreprise euh quand on était élu et
alors je le dirais même pas pour
Monsieur Roussel parce que j'ai bien
compris tout ce qui était derrière mais
et et là ça s'adresse bien sûr aussi à
Madame le Maire et euh euh en fait parce
que vous l'avez cité à plusieurs
reprises vous avez dit je suis compressé
je suis compressé alors ce qui m'a un
peu choqué c'est que vous avez fait le
choix enfin pas de votre part bien sûr
mais que vous avez dû quand même
demander à votre employeur s'il était
d'accord pour vous pour vous laisser
vous présenter ce qui était quand même
ce qui peut laisser à à à interrogation
et et donc aujourd'hui la question c'est
de savoir si une valorisation mais pas
que pécunière mais en tout cas de cette
expérience parce que chacun l'a rappelé
qu'au travers de de la gestion de d'un
mandat c'est c'est une véritable
expérience mais qui à ma connaissance
n'est pas valorisée au sein d'entreprise
donc je le verrai aussi par par rapport
à Madame le Maire c'est de se dire
aujourd'hui l'entreprise
considère-t-elle que cette expérience de
maire était aussi une valeur ajoutée
pour elle alors je je connaissance de
cause enfin pour connaître un peu le
sujet c'est que c'est vrai que ça peut
être une valeur ajoutée quand la plupart
vous demande une dérogation en crèche ou
un permis de construire parce par que là
pour le coup vos collègues se rappellent
que vous êtes élu mais après c'est un
peu plus compliqué donc voilà c'était
c'était mes deux questions de de manière
assez transversal pour l'ensemble des
intervenants je vous
remercie euh notre collègue Pascal
grenny cher Pascal merci madame la
Présidente je vais me permettre de
saluer très personnellement mon
excollègue de l'Assemblée nationale
Daniel fidla avec qui j'ai CGé quelques
quelques années euh donc moi je voudrais
juste soutenir monsieur monsieur Roussel
parce que moi étant une une suppléante
he députée suppléante euh mais mon mon
titulaire est devenu ministre avec des
allers-retours donc j'ai conservé mon
métier qui était directeur financiers et
ressources humaines dans une entreprise
donc je sais ce que c'est que que cette
difficulté et mon collègue vient de dire
la chance pour l'entreprise alors la
chance pour l'entreprise c'est surtout
quand ils ont des questions personnelles
pour entreprise là c'est une vraie
chance après c'est euh voilà
débrouillez-vous mais vous avez un
objectif c'est de respecter les
échéances et de faire votre votre
travail donc c'est c'est une vraie vraie
question à laquelle je je réfléchis
souvent sans trouver beaucoup beaucoup
de de de solutions mais je voulais
partager par rapport à ça mais un autre
un événement chez chez moi pour un un
maère d'une commune de 200 habitants euh
qui malheureusement a a eu dans dans sa
commune un petit garçon violé et tué qui
l'a
retrouvé lui parce que il a aidé les
gendarmes et cetera il a retrouvé bien
entendu il connaissait ce petit la
famille et tout et derrière il a il a
fait une dépression hein voilà compliqué
et là la question et à laquelle bien
entendu on n eu aucune réponse
c'est-à-dire ne n'a pas pu se mettre on
va dire en retrait de sa fonction de
mère parce que il avait besoin d'
arrêter voilà un moment et en fait la
seule chose c'était de démissionner et
dans une petite commune de 200 habitants
B vous trouvez pas quelqu'un qui va vous
vous remplacer derrière euh en revanche
il faudrait peut-être réfléchir à ce que
momentanément voilà 1emier adjoint
puisse officier pour permettre justement
ça là c'était pour une dépression mais
moi j'ai déjà vu la même chose pour des
des maladies graves importantes donc ça
c'est c'est à partager je sais je sais
pas si les mairres qui sont ici ont ont
cette question ensuite j'avais j'avais
une question une réflexion parce que bon
j'étaé vice-présidente jusqu'au mois de
de septembre et dans ma délégation j'ai
travaillé bien entendu j'ai eu le covid
et donc sur la visioconférence et j'ai
entendu monsieur monsieur ga parler de
cette visioconférence pour pour le
quorum et moi en fait j'ai on a limité
au maximum les visioconférences parce
que moi mon sujet c'est si on commence à
mettre la visionférence possible et bien
on va retrouver des salles vides et plus
de contact et c'est ça en fait aussi Qui
est qui est compliqué aujourd'hui je
suis aussi conseiller départemental on a
la même question nous a fait voter
justement pour savoir si si on accepit
que les les sessions elles se fassent en
visioconférence moi j'ai voté contre
voilà parce que je pense qu'on a besoin
de de de ce de ce contact et qui
derrière aussi va sur la question que
vous vous disiez sur sur l'engagement et
ma question c'est l'engagement des
jeunes dont vous parlez don vous êtes un
exemple mais vous êtes un étudiant vous
enfin vous avez fait des études non mais
des études supérieures et cetera moi je
vous demande l'engagement des jeunes qui
sont en ruralité où là c'est vraiment
très très compliqué voilà mes questions
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup donc
peut-être la parole à Madame le Maire
d'pouville pour la question de de Cédric
chevalier et puis ensuite les questions
de notre collègue Pascal greni je
considère que c'est un témoignage très
encourageant voilà peut-être les les no
nos amis qui sont là pourront répondre
donc Madame le Maire si vous voulez bien
répond très rapidement oui je je vais
tenter de répondre très rapidement
est-ce que c'est une valeur ajoutée
d'avoir un maire comme moi pour mon
employeur très franchement je ne le
pense pas même si j'ai la chance d'avoir
un employeur plutôt conciliant et et
auquel bien sûr pourquoi j'ai demandé si
je pouvais devenir maèire parce que si
du du fait que j'ai un poste à
responsabilité je savais que ça allait
poser un problème à l'entreprise et ça
pose un problème à l'entreprise le fait
que je sois pas là le lundi après-midi
que je sois pas là le mercredi
après-midi que parfois au dernier moment
à cause des réunions de communauté
urbaines je suis obligée de changer mes
demi-journées pour pouvoir assister à
certaines réunions ce matin il a fallu
que je dise à mon employeur je ne
pourrais pas être là avant 11h ce matin
et donc je décale mes horaires dans la
journée donc non je pense pas que ce
soit une valeur ajoutée très franchement
alors oui parfois je peux faciliter
certaines chos quand on sur P de000 on
on pose un permis de construire ça peut
m'arriver de faciliter les choses avec
les services de l'urbanisme mais très
franchement non c'est pas facilitateur
pour l'employeur parce que il n'a pas
son cadre me concernant à disposition
comme il devrait l'avoir quelque part
objectivement
donc le la chose à à peut-être à à
trouver c'est comment est-ce qu'on on
peut permettre
finalement que que l'absence je dirais
ou ou partielle ou ou totale d'un d'un
d'un élu d'un salarié élu et et quel
quel biais quelle solution on peut
trouver justement pour que l'employeur
ne soit pas non plus pénalisé je peux
tout à fait comprendre que mon employeur
ben il y a des moments c'est c'est mon
employeur qui s'adapte un peu à moi
parce que ça fait longtemps que je suis
dans l'entreprise qu'on me fait
confiance et cetera mais mais ça
pourrait ne pas être le cas et en même
temps oui je disais que j'étais comprimé
parce que parce que ben voilà je me sens
un petit peu coupable de ne pas être
dans l'entreprise quand je suis à la
mairie et inversement parce que je sais
que j'ai tout un un tas de choses qui
m'attendent aussi dans l'entreprise de
par mon poste à responsabilité donc
honnêtement je je pense que ce n'est pas
facile du tout pour une entreprise
d'avoir un élu d'avoir un élu
euh qui qui doit s'absenter bien
évidemment moi en l'occurrence je suis
deux demi-journées et parfois trois ça
dépend des semaines chargé et parfois ça
m'arrive de retourner travailler le
dimanche euh c'est-à-dire j'y retourne
ou le dimanche matin ou le dimanche
après-midi pour pour quand même bien que
mes heures soient non rémunérées mes
heures de délégation sont non rémunérées
ben j'y retourne parce qu'il y a
tellement de travail aussi que à un
moment donné il faut que le travail se
fasse donc quelle est la solution je ne
l'ai pas mais en tout cas je pense que
c'est pas vraiment une valeur ajoutée
pour une entreprise d'avoir un élu voilà
je c'est le fond de ma pensé
merci beaucoup madame le ma monsieur
Rousel vous souhaitiez répondre et
ensuite je passerai la parole à nos
trois collègues nous sommes aussi
comprimé comprissé par par le temps
votre mot est très juste madame le Maire
Monsieur Russel oui alors moi je j'ai un
avis un tout petit peu différent c'est
vrai que c'est une contrainte puisque
comme je l'ai dit on s'absente on a on a
des emplois du temps qu'il faut adapter
tout le temps et c'est difficile de
concilier plusieurs emplois du temps
parler de vie personnelle aussi donc
j'en ai pas parlé tout à l'heure mais ça
fait tr TR agendas à gérer en même temps
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
et c'est ça peut être une petite
contrainte pour l'entreprise mais d'un
autre côté quand on est élu on est un
peu hyperactif de nature et quand même
organisé on a l'habitude de jongler avec
beaucoup de choses donc par rapport à
d'autres qui ont besoin de quelque chose
de structuré de routinier nous on n'est
pas dans la routine on aime bien ce qui
est varié donc c'est aussi une richesse
à mon avis pour l'entreprise et puis moi
qui a un métier qui est quand même assez
avec une partie commerciale je peux vous
assurer quand on parle avec des
directeurs financiers ou des directeurs
généraux des présidents
d'entreprise quand on glisse dans la
conversation qu'on est élu ils sont bien
plus intéressés que le boulot que les
relations qu'on est en train de
travailler donc les relations
professionnelles elles sont elles sont
vraiment facilitées quand on en vient à
discuter avec le l'expérience qu'on a
par ailleurs merci beaucoup donc je je
n'ai pas oublié la question sur la
vision mais on fera peut-être une petite
réponse technique après donc Pierrejean
Rochette notre collègue également Muriel
jondard et son a de la provoté pour
cette dernière série de questions parce
que nous avons une autre table ronde
avec les associations des luges monsieur
blanc je ne veux frustrer non ù vous
pouvez est-ce que vous voulez bien
déporter votre droit de question à la
séquence suivante c'est formidable parce
que c'est le même sujet merci beaucoup
euh donc euh Pierre Jean Rochette merciè
présidante je vais essayer d'être bref
oui je dois je dois j'ai déjà alors
après on est comprimé on a la pression
tout tout devient difficile voilà je
voulais dire avant en prembu à mon
intervention que je rejoins le maire de
re sur le fait que je pense qu'il y aura
forcément une réflexion à avoir sur le
calibrage en fait du nombre d'élus dans
les dans les communes de taille un petit
peu dans les communes rurales alors ce
qu'on traite ici et ce qu'on traite dans
les échanges que nous avons c'est la
difficulté de cohabitation entre le
monde du travail principalement et le
statut de
l'élu et il y a un double problème c'est
que je pense que nous sommes victimes
des abus aussi du passé que nous sommes
à la fois sous le feu des projecteurs et
très scruté par nos
administrés et à ce titre là je trouve
que justement nous sommes allés beaucoup
trop loin en ce qui concerne notamment
les missions liées à la
chatvp et je trouve que c'est dissuasif
aujourd'hui de s'engager dans une dans
un mandat sachant qu'on va devoir
déballer toute sa vie privée personnelle
et qu'elle sera accessible à tout le
monde sur internet à la limite ça me
dérange pas de la déballer mais qu'elle
soit accessible uniquement par une
partie par par les gens qui ont à exercé
un droit de contrôle et un droit de
regard sur nous mais qu'on sache le le
travail de mon épouse c'est revenu le le
avec qui vivent mes enfants s'ils sont
majeur enfin je trouve que c'est d'une
indessence totale et ça ne ça ne
facilite pas et ça ne rend pas le statut
de l'élu attractif je trouve que c'est
malsin en plus oui je vais aller vite
j'ai compris tu levais le doigt pour que
j'aille plus vite dans le dans le dans
la relation avec les entreprises les
élus maintenant je pense font peur aux
entreprises et font peur au
monde font peur au patron si ça a été un
avantage dans le passé ça ne l''est plus
aujourd'hui
la commande publique c'est plus de 100
milliards d'euros en France 8 % du PIB
il y a forcément des élus qui
travaillent dans des entreprises qui ont
un lien avec la commande publique avec
les difficultés qu'il y a aujourd'hui
sur justement les sujets liés au déports
justement les sujets liés au conflit
d'intérêt les élus deviennent des
mistigeris dans les entreprises moi j'ai
pas peur d'employer le terme les élus
deviennent des mistigeris et je pense
que tant que nous n'aurons pas régler ce
sujetl nous irons à des aberrations et
j'ai eu le cas et j'en terminerai
présidente
dans des dans des communes rurales de
mon département où on demandait aux
agriculteurs qui étaient dans le conseil
municipal de se mettre en déport lors de
la rédaction du PLU parce qu'on faisait
une interprétation
très très littérale de la loi et et et
on va vers des aberrations où il y avait
même le boulanger d'un village qui se
disait mais je suis au conseil municipal
j'ai plus le droit de livrer la cantine
donc on va fair le pain d'une autre
commune enfin on va dans des trucs
complètement absurdes délirant et
là-dessus nous sommes allés beaucoup
trop loin et ça tuera ça tuera les les
les les les ambitions les envies les les
les les vocations d'élus sur le long
terme et je pense qu'on a un énorme
travail à faire
là-dessus merci beaucoup on sait on sait
que c'est un sujet récurrent et juste
une anecdote d'un conseiller municipal
qui me un moment je me demande si élu de
cette commune et habitant cette commune
je vais avoir le droit de voter le taux
de taxe
d'habitation alors Muriel qui va être
aussi concise que nos nos collègues
Sonia qui va l'être encore plus parce
que il y a une seconde table ronde c'est
infernal de de comprimer
chacun merci madame la Présidente alors
ma question va peut-être être d'autant
plus provocquante qu'elle va être
concise donc peu nuancée moi je pars de
quelques constats le le le le premier
d'abord c'est que me semble-t-il les
maires et les élus sont utiles on parle
beaucoup de réduire le nombre d'élus
mais il me me semble qu'aujourd'hui pour
être tout à fait clair dans ma pensée ce
sont les communes qui tiennent la France
et notamment les petites communes parce
qu'elles tiennent elles tiennent le
quotidien deuxième chose il me semble
utile d'avoir des maires qui ne soient
pas seulement retraités mais aussi
actifs on l'a tous dit c'est une vision
différente des choses troisièmement
c'est assez difficile de conserver un
travail et une activité d'élu chacun l'a
compris sauf peut-être les
disponibilités des des fonctionnaires
mais lorsqu'on a une profession libérale
les clients nous attendent pas et
lorsqu'on est salarié du privé il est
assez normal que l'entreprise veuille
que vous fassiez le travail pour lequel
elle vous a embauché pour lequel elle
vous paye et donc partant du principe
que cette fonction on l'a indiqué tout à
l'heure enfin il faut être spécialiste
en tout ce qui est tout à fait paradoxal
mais ce sont des généralistes
spécialisés les maires on a des journées
extrêmement prenantes et comme elles
n'ont que 24 heures et c'est un peu le
constat ben on se trouve en difficulté
pour avoir plusieurs activités qui sont
prenantes comme l'activité
professionnelle et l'activité de Mare
est-ce que partant de tous ces constats
la solution n'est pas que tout
simplement on accepte de rémunérer
correctement les mairres à hauteur des
responsabilités et du temps qu'il passe
avec de vrais droits à la retraite et
qu'ensuite chacun admette aussi que être
élu c'est un choix personnel qui
comporte un risque celui de ne pas être
réélu et que celui-là on l'assume voilà
madame la Présidente ce qui est bien
dans votre temps concis vous faites et
les questions et les réponses euh donc
non mais moi je vous félicite parce que
je je n'osais pas demander de faire tout
ça en 5 minutes mais votre diagnostic je
pense est extrêmement sénatorial et très
partager sur tous les ban merci beaucoup
de cette concision cette clarté et de
cette incision si je puis dire Sonia oui
mais merci donc archi comprimé
Sonia chers amis parce que nos invités
sont AR bien c'est ça cher Sonia nos
invités suivants sont arrivés donc je
vais fairedre l'absence de nuanceces
mais comme ils me connaissent bien tout
le monde compris donc je vais d'abord
aborder la question des femmes c'est pas
du tout féministe ce que je vais dire
mais c'est très c'est très très réaliste
euh voilà la question de la maternité
alors je sais bien que l'auditoire si
quand même il y a peut-être une personne
qui peut en parler un peu plus en
connaissance de cause mais c'est un vrai
sujet c'est qu'on parle de la vie
professionnelle mais parfois il y a
trois vies à assumer et la vie
personnelle c'est aussi gérer ça et
c'est un c'est un énorme un énorme sujet
alors pour le coup je peux faire un
témoignage personnel sur sur cette
question si on a beaucoup oup d'énergie
et qu'on arrive à concilier les trois
vies c'est formidable puceque j'avais
mon métier à côté mais sinon je pense
que dans la plupart des cas c'est une
difficulté immense et donc je pose cette
question et la deuxième question
concerne le soutien psychologique parce
que ça a été un peu évolué évoqué tout à
l'heure parce qu'on parle de la violence
l'agressivité et cetera mais il y a
aussi les moments tragiques que l'on vit
qui sont des moments particulièrement
impactants quand on n' pas l'habitude de
gérer moi je suis médecin de formation
donc j'avais un petit peu de bagage pour
assurer certaines situations mais j'ai
vu autour de moi des élus qui ont quand
même eu des des des vraies conséquences
personnelles psychologiques des
situations qu'ils ont vécu et donc ça
c'est un un un deuxième sujet je vous
remercie j'espère avoir été assez courte
madame euh oui et je pense que vous avez
été parfaite et que les collègues me
disent qu'ils ont les réponses alors ils
vont pas nous les donner aujourd'hui un
peu de teasing euh une partie euh voilà
j'aimerait peut-être qu'on ait un petit
mot très technique sur la vision qui est
un vrai sujet parce que on l'a débattu
ici au Sénat alors on répondra pas mais
il y a effectivement la facilitation par
que vous dites on peut donner des
pouvoirs ne pas être là et en même temps
comment on
respecte ce ce cette nécessité de
présence physique et de rencontre pour
nourrir un débat puisque nos assemblées
ne sont pas que techniques donc je ne
sais pas qui veut répondre monsieur
Fidelin et Monsieur G vous avez à vous
deux à partager 2 minutes
euh voilà la
visioconférence c'est vrai que lorsque
je suis venu ici on m'a proposé de faire
mon intervention en
visioconférence j'ai refusé parce que
moi je crois beaucoup si vous voulez au
contact parce que j'avais le temps parce
que je vais pas avec mes collègues mes
anciens collègue notamment Épouville que
je connais très bien elle a beaucoup de
travail beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle donc elle est en
visionférence mais moi je préfère
effectivement d'être euh on peut
débattre on regarde un peu les personnes
a dans les yeux avec qui on est en face
et puis on peut reprendre un peu les les
euh les débats donc moi je pense que
c'est quand même le meilleur des choses
merci avez-vous une demi-minute de
réponse oui merci Madame la Présidente
je vais rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
Daniel Fidelin c'est vrai que moi on m'a
également proposé de le faire en visio
et j'ai refusé j'ai préféré être présent
euh et j'aimerais madame la la sénatrice
alors je peux pas vous regarder je suis
désolé mais j'aimerais nuancer peut-être
l'argument de l'engagement et de la
visioconférence je pense que Madame et
et Messieurs les maires en
visioconférence ne sont pas plus
désengagés que nous et et en ce sens la
visioconférence doit être un outil qui
qui doit être utilisableon é alors
peut-être pas illimité j'entends bien
mais peut-être réfléchir à des à des
quotas à des les possibilités de de de
Séan et je pense puisque ça se fait même
en commission dans les commissions sport
et les commissions thématiques locales
pourquoi pas ne pas le faire pour les
conseils locaux je pense que c'est une
nécessité et ça reviendrait aussi à à
développer ce statut deélu étudiant
parce qu'il y a des étudiants qui
étudient très loin et qui ne peuvent pas
prendre le train l'avion pour revenir en
conseil municipal départemental ou
régional merci merci beaucoup en tout
cas moi je veux tous vous remercier vous
et vous saluer parce que vos témoignages
é
extrêmement intéressant je crois que ça
nourrit nos nos réflexions ça conforte
nos nos corapporteurs que je remercie et
sur la vision je je je voudrais dire moi
je j'apporte pas du tout de réponse sur
le sujet mais je veux adresser un salut
particulier aux élus qui étaient avec
nous en visio pour la qualité aussi d'
Témo et que je trouve que la Viso est
aussi un outil pour nous permettre
d'échanger et d'entendre
des collègues ou des personnes qui pour
des raisons soit professionnelles soit
lointaines ne peuvent pas parfois
consacrer une journée de déplacement
pour une rencontre jourée et que je
pense que c'est un véritable
atout notamment pour la ruralité
c'est-à-dire on a accès à des choses et
je veux vraiment vous remercier vous
dire que je suis consciente de votre
frustration parce
que voilà on n pas eu sans doute le
temps que vous auriez souhaité mais
sachez que les corapporteurs sont à
votre disposition et que si vous
souhaitez faire des contributions
complémentaires n'hésitez pas à les
apporter en tout cas vraiment mille
merci à tous de ces de ces échanges et
merci à tous nos collègues qui étaient
nombreux et qui je crois ont été tous
extrêmement intéressés et j'espère que
vous sentez que le Sénat voilà porte vos
préoccupations et que cela a été dit il
n'y a pas d'avenir pour nos territoires
Dieu sait si au Sénat nous pensons qu'il
y a pas d'avenir pour notre pays s'il y
a pas d'avenir dans les territoires il y
aura pas d'avenir pour les territoire si
les élus n'en ont plus et je pense que
nous la mission que nous faisons n'est
pas une mission de désespérance ou de
désespoir mais bien au contraire une
mission d'espérance et de confiance
sachant que on le dit la la République
n'a pas de prix mais elle a un coup et
qu'il faut savoir le reconnaître et
sortir de cette démagogie et de ce
populisme fort désagréable et nuisible
qui consistait à faire du baching d'élus
chaque citoyen doit pouvoir se présenter
la France faut l' a besoin de ses élus
il faut un travail formidable et nous
nous en sommes fiers nous y croyons ici
dans la chambre des territoires nous
pensons que la République doit affirmer
le respect qu'elle doit aux élus et ce
qu'elle lui doit tout court donc mille
merci euh à vous tous c'était de belles
rencontre merci beaucoup merci à tous
merci
voilà donc j'enchaîne avec la deuxè
partie qui vont
AR merci et je voulais prévenir les
collègues vous n'êtes pas tous là mais
je vous ah ça m'a fait très plaisir très
bien tu es très bien coaché par ce jeune
élu
anime le sa